thanks to curiositystream for supporting
this episode
go to
curiositystream.com microcosmos to start
streaming thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction tv shows
if you know about the species lacrimaria
allure then you know what you're getting
when you see it under a microscope
there's the oval body the long neck
the grasping and reaching out for food
it has a distinct shape a distinct way
of life the combination of its own
genetics and its surrounding environment
it's also distinct that even when you
look at different lack of maria allure
and see that sure these individuals
don't necessarily look exactly alike you
can still spot the underlying framework
of the species that makes them resemble
each other
you see the morphology and the behavior
all united under the name lacrimaria
allure
[Music]
it's like looking at a house cat
you know they have their own colors and
patterns and preferences
but at the same time it makes sense why
we might consider them all to be the
same species felis katis then you look
at the species felis manuel
better known as palace's cat
and the idea that these two are
relatives of each other also feels right
there's a sense of same but different
and that can make the idea of a species
seem simple enough
there are things that are like each
other and there are things that are less
like each other
so the idea of a species is to define
individuals so that we can define groups
so that we can define relationships
except it is never so simple when it
comes to trying to categorize life
because at the end of the day species
are only a little bit about the
organisms we're looking at
they're really more about us and how we
see the world
life is complicated and evolving which
means it will always be pushing against
the bounds of our categorization
but that doesn't mean we can't try
the human attempt to define a species is
an exercise in futility that is
nonetheless vital to our understanding
of biology
it provides us with a language to
describe the world around us so that we
can make comparisons and find patterns
so
what even is a species
well it depends on who you ask
there have been several species concepts
over the past few centuries
one of the definitions you may be
familiar with is attributed to the
zoologist ernst meyer who in 1942
defined species as
groups of actually or potentially
interbreeding natural populations which
are reproductively isolated from other
such groups
this describes what is known as the
biological species concept
two species might look the same
but if they can't reproduce together
then they're different
one of the major challenges with this
definition is obvious from our journey
through the microcosmos
not all organisms interbreed
some reproduce asexually
so how does one draw biological borders
around species that just make copies of
themselves
there are several other species concepts
out there and we won't be able to
explore all of them in this episode
but one of the other salient definitions
that helps avoid the challenges of the
biological species concept is similar to
how we started this episode
just look at the organisms
look at their morphology describe their
shape and color in organelles and
whatever strange features appear
and use that to define an individual
species
it seems as simple as saying that if
it's almond shaped in body and long and
neck then it's lacrimaria allure
why make it any more complicated than
that
but deciding on what traits define a
morphological species is so dependent on
who is observing and describing those
traits
and it creates so many more questions
for how we use morphology to describe
species and their taxonomy
what if the neck is a little shorter the
body a little stouter
does that make it a different species
and just how much can we infer about the
relationships between two species based
on their appearance
if they look similar does that mean
they're close relatives or is that some
kind of phylogenetic optical illusion
there's no single answer to any of those
questions
it all just depends on the organisms and
what it is you want to understand about
them
[Music]
let's look at lacrimaria sapropelica
a fellow member of the lacrimaria genus
its body is stout compared to the
lacrimaria allure like setting down a
teapot next to a champagne glass
most importantly its neck doesn't seem
to extend much beyond its body
instead of the constant stretching
movement of the lacrimaria allure's neck
the lacrimaria cypropelica's neck is
stubby and immobile
in fact it looks a little bit like this
other species called phylena cowdatum
which belongs to the genus violina a
genus that closely resembles lacrimaria
except for the obvious issue of the neck
so if lacro maria sapropelica doesn't
have an extending neck
why is it classified as lacrimaria and
not violina
well
mostly because no one's taken the time
to officially change it
naming and classifying species doesn't
just happen automatically
a person has to come along and do it
putting in the effort to study the
creatures and write up their reasons for
changing its identity
and you know
sometimes that person just hasn't come
along
that's the thing about people we've come
up with these incredible systems for
describing nature
but at the end of the day
those systems are still subject to our
very human whims
and just to emphasize how messy the
process of organizing organisms is
we should add that phylena count adam
actually went by another name before
lacro maria coudadam
but unlike lacrimarius apropelica
someone did come along and do the work
of revising its place
we don't know what motivated them to
take on the species
maybe they were constantly irritated
when they read the words lacrimaria
caudada
maybe they just happened to be studying
the species already
or they just wanted to publish a paper
or maybe it's a combination of all three
human motivations and desires are just
as difficult to categorize as microbes
all this messiness and subjectivity
seems built into morphology
but we live in the age of genetics now
where sequencing an organism is cheap in
the data objective
right
yes and no
there are ways that molecular phylogeny
the use and comparison of genetic
sequences to understand evolutionary
relationships has allowed us to see past
the surface similarities between
organisms
amoebas for example were thought to be
closely related because of their use of
pseudopodia or false feet but their
genetic underpinnings revealed that
amoebas are actually the culmination of
many different species and groups and
phyla that just happen to resemble each
other in this one major way and those
results the specificity they've allowed
us in redefining these species
have given us new understanding about
their evolution and behaviors
but data as concrete and undeniable as
it feels
is still in the eye of the beholder
like let's say we found a new species
with a short non-extending neck
and say we decided to name it lacromaria
microcosmosi
we're excited to find it and we're even
more excited to study it and report all
the genetic information we can find
describing the organism in terms of its
genetic code that we registered to a
depository for other scientists to look
at
but then let's say that shortly after
our discovery other masters of
microscopes turn up their own lacromaria
microcosmosity discoveries
the morphologies match what we've
described
but when we compare our genetic
sequences to what they've found
there are differences
the question is how big do those
differences have to be to make the
organism itself different
do they define a new species an entirely
new genus
at what point do we decide
something is too different to be the
same or even just similar
that's not necessarily a problem that
dna and computers will be able to solve
for us
there's still going to be a person who
has to decide
a person who has to make a subjective
call based on the data presented and the
questions asked
and their definition will probably have
exceptions too
leaving blanks in our understanding
but blinks are exciting
they leave us room for new ways of
seeing things of asking things
because our definitions are an attempt
to bring the expansiveness of biology
into something we can understand
something we can speak and read
but life expands beyond those
constraints
in ways we know in ways we have yet to
find out
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
this episode has been brought to you by
curiosity stream a subscription
streaming service that offers thousands
of documentaries and non-fiction tv
shows from some of the world's best
filmmakers including award-winning
exclusives and originals
they cover topics like history nature
science food technology travel and more
and since we're already on the topic of
long-necked creatures why not check out
the documentary the woman who loves
giraffes it's the story of andag a
zoologist who in 1956
took a solo journey to south africa to
study giraffes in the wild and helped
pioneer the field of giraffe biology
and you can find it right now on
curiosity stream
you can stream curiosity streams library
including their collections of curated
programs handpicked by their experts to
any device for viewing anytime anywhere
and if you go to
curiositystream.com microcosmos and use
the code microcosmos to sign up it will
only cost you 14.99 for an entire year
the names you're seeing on the screen
right now they are people who are
supporting us on patreon
patreon is a place where you can go and
give a little bit of money to the things
that you really think should exist in
the world
and all of those people really think
that journey to the microcosmos should
exist
and we agree with them and we're so
thankful to them
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you